Hey how's it going bros?
My name is pew-
HOMYGOD
WHAT?
What is it?
You're so cringey
EVERYTIME
Im so disgusted to be associated with you...
LISTEN
I challenge you
to a CRINGE OFF
with a try not to cringe challenge
*zooms in dat face*
OH I ACCEPT YOUR CHALLENGE!!
Nothing makes me cringe more than me
So I gladly *pauses*
ACCEPT YOUR CHALLENGE
You folks at home can play along with this
Try not to cringe challenge
game
that we came up with
You know I haven't even watched this video and I
and I already absolutely fucking loathe it.
But let's watch
HOW BAD COULD IT BE?
bee bee bee beep
P-P-A-P
WELL RIGHT OFF THE BAT
THAT FUCKING FONT
IS LIKE THE STANDARD FUCKING FONT
IN PREMIERE
IF YOU SEE ANYONE WITH THAT FONT
JUST
FUCK 'EM
THE GOAL IS TO NOT CRINGE. REMEMBER, KIDS
*dances fabulously in rhythm*
UHHHHN
so cringeeeee
uhhh
UHHH
pen pinapple papu pen
This fucking guy
got 9 million views of this trend??
I have a pen, I have an apple
UHH APPLE PEN
Now the real cringe begins
*exhales* ohhh
I have a pen, I have pineapple
oohhh
Uhh
no don't recreate it (too late)
Apple pen, OH GOD pineapple pen
OH GOD HE'S RECREATING IT
UGHH
He put himself in there...
This kind of shit makes me wanna die
5, 4, 3, 2, 1
Oh no. Celebrities doing stuff on stage
Oh no
Press that button!
Oh nooooo
*crying for Justin Timberlake*
YOU HAD ONE JOB, BUTTON!
YOU HAD ONE
FUCKING JOB
BUTTON!
WHY
CAN'T YOU SEE JUSTIN TIMBERLAKE IS IN PAIN?!
Keep trying to press the button, Justin Timberlake
Justin Timberlake,
Did you try pressing the button?
He didn't press the button???
KEEP TRYING TO PRESS THE BUTTON
Anna Kendrick,
Try and laugh it off
*Anna's nervous laughter*
Well congratulations, guys
Oh my God
*attractive stare*
NO
OKAY HERE'S THE TIP
*claps*
Cringe school with Pewdiepie, okay???
Number 1....
I you're ever on a live gaming event,
now under no circumstances
whatsoever......
DO NOT TRY
AND SHAKE
THE GUY'S HAND
I already know- We all know what's gonna happen
I will see you back
in one month
*Iris plays in the background*
*moans and touches himself*
*chokes*
*shot in the heart by an invisible bullet*
That's the same face I did
at Conan
That's the-
I'm dead inside (same)
facing-
Shit, this shit's gonna be live
on tv forever
This is gonna be in a cringe compilation
goddamit
OH GOD NOT ANOTHER ONE
I CANT.
FELIX, Why do you do this to me???
You know its my ultimate weakness
Thank you so much for you time
*holds hand like he's gonna propose*
OH NO
OoooOOOoOOooOOooOOoOHHHhH
So you have a normal guy
ultimate no cringe, whatsoever
and then you have thissss
Dark creature of the night..
CRINGE
UGGGGHHH
GREAT
OH
oooHHHH
HOOOOOOOO
*HAND LEFT IN THE AIR, AGAIN*
OH SHE'S COMMITING!!
OH GOD THAT COMMITMENT
OHH HO HO *starts timer*
If you're failing, you gotta commit
And oh boy, does she commit
That takes balls
*applause for her*
That takes real fucking balls
LOOK AT HER FACE
She's like YEP
yEP
i fucked up
Well Im gonna commit to it
*laughs*
They're watching American Beauty today
American Beauty???
UHH IT HURTS
UGGGGHHH
Adam's apple, y'all
UHH
Cringe school with Pewdiepie. Lesson number 500
If you're gonna talk to someone about something,
related to them
and you never met before you met them,
you better damn make sure you know what the fuck you talkin about
ESPECIALLY A CELEBRITY
What's wrong with the rose petals?
No
Really?
Really...
Swear to God
why do you keep
do you think he's fucking lying???
You fucking dumb white bitch
jeezus christ
what is your deck name?
*awkward silence*
*bursts into laughter*
*wheezing*
WHAT...
WHAT??
SLIPPY
*Iris plays*
At least acknowledge that it was a shit joke. Just be like, you know what?
That was pretty shit
Just do that
Just give him that
Don't murder him like that
DON'T MURDER HIM WITH A DEAD LOOK
Jack: Hi! Nice outfit!
Hove you seen The Chef?
Ohh
Have a seen the shift?*confused look*
ohh
he did a meme
I..guess..not..
'cause I don't know what that is
*bursts in anger* HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT CHEF IS
OHHHH MY GODDDDD
WHAT A FUCKING IDIOT
He hasn't seen- He doesn't even know what it is
Chef. Let me tell you
Chef is a great movie
about a man
that used to be a 5-star restaurant chef
but then, he loses his business
so he decided to start a food truck
and it's AMAYZENG
Such a great film
That really inspires me
I felt so inspired
after I saw Chef
Got a great soundtrack,
great character development and great story
Thank you, idubs
for asking the right question
and Jacksepticeye, as always,
You're a fucking moron
*woman dancing in an airplane*
iJustine I'm sorry
Why- Why would you do that? why
Stop
oh don't clap
Don't clap. Thats so-
Clapping on airplanes
should be forbidden
I know this one part that's like,
oh man
thats
She got balls to do that in public
Which I can respect cause a lot of people couldn't pull this shit up
The problem is that it's just not funny
these people can't go anywhere they have to stand this girl
being fucking annoying
Okay, last video
OK
GREAT another fucking handshake?
jeezus christ
NOT THE HANDSHAKE
"fuck i should've used the other hand, mom was right"
Literally, that was as painful as seeing all their dicks touch
jesus, STOP
STOP WITH THE HANDSHAKES
NO MORE HAND SHAKES :(
BAN HAND SHAKES
How bout we just do this?
Hey how you doin?  (joey fom friends?)
Minecraft is my life
sub4sub and like4like XD